[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you all for
joining us this afternoon
for another Talks
at Google event.
We're very thrilled to have
Alison Bing from Lonely Planet
to speak to us today
about high-impact travel.
She's the author of over
45 books for Lonely Planet,
specifically for
us locally here,
the San Francisco, coastal
California ones, among others.
And so she'll talk
about her experiences
writing for Lonely Planet.
And when she's not
doing that, she
also helps Google out
with our Brand Studio
and works and writes for
several other publications
nationwide as well.
So please join me in
welcoming Alison to Google.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ALISON BING: Thanks, everyone.
So we're going to be
talking a little bit
today about high-impact travel.
As you know, you can't--
by the time you
arrive in an airplane,
you already have a huge
carbon footprint to offset.
And travel is more satisfying
when it's a positive exchange,
because nobody likes to be a
burden or show up empty handed.
When a friend invites
you to dinner,
you just automatically
ask what you can bring,
and making that contribution
feels really good.
So when you travel to
an unfamiliar place,
you don't even know who to
ask what you could bring.
Showing up with
nothing offer gets
things started on
the wrong foot.
You've already got that carbon
footprint to think about,
and it feels like a
lopsided transaction.
It's a drain on local
resources, and it feels awkward.
So to make a
positive impression,
sometimes we show up with
kind of a token gift.
A San Francisco
Giants t-shirt, maybe.
Three-time World Series
champions, you know?
Well, neither did my Lonely
Planet editor in London.
He was not very impressed.
He was like, baseball?
We have cricket.
So yeah.
It went over better in a
Moroccan village in the High
Atlas Mountains where
I brought a t-shirt,
and it was promptly torn up into
strips and woven into a rug.
So it's not what I
pictured, but you know, OK.
But it was a terrible
flop in Italy
where the horrified
Italian friend I gave it to
gave me a lecture,
saying, you need to--
Americans need to make your
t-shirts fit more tightly.
And he was like, for the
sake of humanity, you know?
Fix your fashion.
So I learned the hard way.
But you know, as a travel
writer, that's my job.
I make mistakes so that you
don't have to make them.
So don't bring the t-shirts.
Bring something else.
Bring something more meaningful.
Like what?
So I'm glad you asked.
First thing you can
bring is suitcase space.
So travelers often pride
themselves on traveling light,
but they're missing
out on an opportunity
to connect with people
in their destination,
because carrying just a
little extra weight is
a small but tangible
act of kindness that
creates powerful bonds.
And there are two important
things you probably
have room for in your suitcase.
One is specific supplies
or in-kind donations
for a destination nonprofit.
Be sure to ask what that
nonprofit needs most.
You know, don't assume that
San Francisco Giants t-shirts
or Google swag, or whatever
you happen to have on hand
is going to be welcome,
especially if you
don't have enough to go around.
This is an orphanage that
I visited in Ethiopia,
and definitely didn't need
San Francisco Giants t-shirts,
but donations were most welcome.
Last summer, when I was invited
to work on a public awareness
campaign for the Ethiopian
Midwives Association,
I asked what hospital
supplies might be helpful.
They asked me to bring
pediatric breathing tubes, which
are inexpensive here, but
really hard to come by there.
And they're essential
to rescue newborns
with respiratory problems.
At the time, I was
working at Apple.
And when I told colleagues
there what I was doing,
they wanted to send tubes too.
So I found out the maximum
number I could carry,
and I weighed my luggage
to the last ounce.
And all those tubes have
been put to use already.
And let me say, not one of
those was woven into a rug.
In fact, they were used by the
doctors you see in this photo.
This is a birth
ceremony that I was
invited to attend in Ethiopia.
And if I look a
little awkward, it's
because I had a
terrible cold that day,
and I was trying not
to touch anything
to make the babies sick.
But the doctor
said, don't worry.
You know, you're fine.
It'll be good for the
antibodies for the babies,
so there you go.
Doctors.
Here's something you're
probably already doing.
Tell colleagues and
friends where you're going,
and ask the people
who lived in that area
if you could take them
for coffee or lunch
to get their suggestions.
So far, that's mostly
benefiting you, right?
But at lunch, if
there's anything
they might like you to deliver
to their friends or family
while you're there, ask.
Nothing huge.
Just mementos.
Photos, letters, maybe a
birthday gift for a kid,
and deliver it in person.
This is a really
meaningful gesture.
Many people with family abroad
can't get away for visits
very often.
And many people are concerned
about re-entry to the US right
now.
Even if your colleague
or friend says no thanks,
they won't forget your kindness.
This is a photo
inside of a guesthouse
where I stayed in Ethiopia.
And these are items
that previous guests
had sent to the host.
She had a thing for baskets
and tinware and tea sets,
and had some from all over.
I brought her Benadryl because
she had allergies, and was
really suffering from
high pollen counts
while I was there.
And she liked the Benadryl,
and I'm invited back.
So that worked.
If they do give you
a memento to deliver,
that's a great way to make new
friends or instant relatives
in an unfamiliar place.
When my best friend
was living in Zimbabwe,
a guy she was dating
visited San Francisco.
And he brought me a bundle
of letters from my friend
and a collage he had made about
a trip they took together.
Smart move.
That's one way to win the
approval of your girlfriend's
best friend.
They're now married.
And as their friend,
I had the honor
of being the justice of
the peace at their wedding
ceremony.
That's me right there.
That's them.
OK.
So your suitcase
is fully loaded.
Nice.
Now what else can you bring?
Research skills.
So wild assumption here.
I'm guessing you know how to
search online, probably better
than anyone on the planet.
So I'm about to
tell you something
that you already know,
especially all you product
people.
To maximize positive impact,
you must do advance research.
Before you even buy
a ticket, research
to figure out where
you want to go,
where you want to stay,
what you want to eat,
what you want to do.
And use impact as a filter.
Protip here.
Lonely Planet flags hotels,
restaurants, sites, stores,
bars, and other venues
with a proven commitment
to sustainability.
In our books, just
look for the Leaf icon.
OK.
So maybe you don't want a
power search on your day off.
I get that.
But don't count on just
showing up and asking
a local for pointers.
In Venice, locals
often complained to me
that tourists were always
asking them for directions.
At first, I thought
they were exaggerating
until I did the math.
Even if every tourist asked
for directions only once,
each Venetian would be asked
on average three times a day.
And Venetian directions
are complicated.
There are hundreds of
footbridges and canals.
It takes time to answer, and
that gets to be an imposition.
So I made sure our
Lonely Planet Venice
maps were really thorough.
And I also encouraged
tourists to consider getting
lost part of the adventure.
I like to think maybe
some Venetians are
being asked for directions
only twice a day now.
And here, you can see
some of the difficulty
that Google Maps is up against
with satellite imagery,
trying to show where
streets end in Venice.
But you know, we
walk those routes.
Also, when you do get
information from a local,
say thanks.
Then stealthily fact
check that information.
Even with the best
intentions, some locals
will cheerfully give you
the wrong information.
Has this happened to you?
OK.
They assume they know all the
best places in their town,
but the truth is, we get
lazy in our backyards.
We're comfortable here.
We can't always be tracking
sustainable restaurant
practices or
nonprofit initiatives,
especially when it's sunny out.
Oh, by the way, these
guys are the proud owners
of a Lonely Planet Leaf icon.
They have practiced sustainable
fishing, support sustainable
fishing.
They serve exclusively
Venetian food.
It's All'Arco in Venice.
And that's Francesco and
his son Mateo behind him.
Quite a team.
I interviewed them.
That's how I know their names.
Otherwise, I'm
usually incognito.
So I know all too
well the problem
of potentially overlooking
something in your own backyard.
I think I know my
city of San Francisco
until I set out to
write the Lonely Planet
guide to San Francisco.
And it turns out, I know my
neighborhood pretty well,
and I know the paths I
take to and from work.
Everything else requires
intensive research.
So I Google search like
crazy, I interview people,
I visit places I uncover through
research, eavesdrop heavily.
I'm listening.
If you're in that
restaurant with me,
I'm probably trying
to hear whether or not
you're liking your food.
And I ask questions of everyone
I meet at a destination.
For example, recent
research indicated
that many diners
were complaining
about a newish restaurant
in San Francisco called Cala
for adding a flat
20% service fee.
So I went to Cala incognito
to eat dinner there,
and I asked people
there about it.
My server was especially
glad I asked her directly,
because it's important
to her, and she feels
it's been misconstrued online.
I hear that kind of
thing can happen.
Turns out that
their fixed service
fee is part of a city program
to rehabilitate people
who have been incarcerated
for nonviolent crimes, usually
drug-related, ensuring a
consistent income so that they
can get back on their feet
and stick with substance abuse
treatment programs.
The story checks out.
So now I can eat a Cala, and I
will, because it's that good.
And I can feel good
about that service fee.
And I can recommend it to
you in good conscience.
So you've filled
your luggage, you've
done your research
to figure out where
you can have an impact
without entirely leaving it up
to locals to educate you.
This is all good, but
there's something else
you may be able to offer.
A willingness to go
the extra mile or 30.
Every dollar you
spend in rural areas
is circulated through the
community four to 10 times more
than in cities.
This is something we discovered
when I was at Airbnb.
The traveler's economic impact
in rural areas is exponential.
But looking at
travel industry data,
we also discovered
that most people
don't venture more than two
hours beyond city limits.
That's a lost opportunity
for rural areas,
but it's our loss
as travelers too.
We're missing out on some
really enriching experiences
in absolutely beautiful places.
Sometimes these places are
not set up for travelers,
so you have to do extra research
to find out where to stay,
what to do, and what to eat.
This is a first
communion that we
stumbled into in Copala,
Mexico, and we're
invited to participate.
And it's just a
few hours outside
of Mazatlan, about
two and a half.
And by the way, this
previous image as well,
two and a half hours from Rome.
It's the town of
Sorano in Tuscany.
So not everybody can do
this extra bit of research,
but you can, because
you are Google.
So look.
I'm not saying it's easy.
Once I was assigned
by Lonely Planet
to find sustainable tourism
options in the remote Ait
Bouguemez Valley in Morocco's
High Atlas Mountains.
Previous editions of
"Lonely Planet Morocco"
mentioned that it was a
beautiful place, ideal
for hiking, but it
sounded kind of scary.
Roads washed out,
food could be scarce,
and few people spoke
European languages or Arabic.
By then, I had already seen
one San Francisco Giants
t-shirt torn to
shreds, so I knew
I had to do my
research before I came.
So I hired a Tachlhit-speaking
guy from the area
with a four-wheel-drive
car, and together, we
visited villages carved
out of cliff faces.
We asked people and village
elders, what do you do here?
What would you like people
to know about this place?
Are there talents or
skills you'd like to share?
And I asked them all
the same question
we're trying to answer today.
If people would like to
repay your hospitality,
how can they best do that?
Working in this
collaborative way
with villagers we
met along the valley,
we were able to find ways to
support initiatives they'd
had in the works for years.
By the time we left
the valley, there
were working models in place
for an after school tea
program at a center for
disabled adults in Demnate.
There was a postcard
pen pal project
to support language acquisition
for eco-trekking guides
in Tabant.
And there were goat
cheese tastings
with the women's
goat herd collective,
which they started against
the will of their parents,
by the way.
Six years later, these
programs are all flourishing.
Travelers' financial support
and overwhelmingly positive
social media posts have
helped expand accessibility
for disabled people
in the valley
and created new jobs
through eco travel.
The women's goat cheese
cooperative has tripled in size
and received international slow
food prizes for their cheese.
Roads have even improved,
much to the relief
of the local donkeys.
And that's the thing
about sustainable travel.
It's not as difficult
as you might
think to be a trailblazer.
All I needed to do was go
a bit further out of my way
and ask a few more questions
than I typically ask.
And when more people go
further and ask more,
we can all accomplish even more.
It's exponential.
Here's how I know that.
Last time I was in Morocco,
I ran a work session
with Peace Corps
volunteers to identify
ways to involve travelers in
local development efforts.
They brought it back to
their communities who
held their own work sessions.
Morocco is also the biggest
Peace Corps site in the Middle
East, and that
information has now
been shared with sites
across the Middle East.
I also got a lot out of it.
Turns out that sustainable
travel road trips are
totally bonding experiences.
Mohamed Nour, the colleague
who accompanied me
as a driver and translator, is
now a friend of mine for life.
And as the result
of our travels,
he's moved to the
Ait Bouguemez Valley.
He's started his own
eco travel business,
and now trains and
mentors eco travel guides.
Like I said, exponential impact.
OK.
So now you've got
a full suitcase.
You've done your
research on impact.
You're ready to go
further and ask more.
Excellent.
I can almost feel your
exponential impact coming.
Almost.
There is one more thing
you can bring with you.
A passion or a belief
that transcends borders.
This could be a big idea like
net neutrality or refugee
support or a vision to
end human trafficking.
That guy on the lower left is
my Google Brand Studio colleague
Ruben Santa-- hi, Ruben--
who joined a team of
eight Googlers in Nepal
for a 20% project
with effect.org
to fight human trafficking.
They met with girls in safe
houses who had escaped slavery
and are now studying,
learning vocational skills,
and becoming advocates for
girls still in captivity.
Ruben and the Google team
use their everyday problem
solving skills to
support some of the NGOs
making an impact on the ground.
I asked Ruben to describe
the impact of the trip on him
personally, and he answered
me with this photo.
Another Google Brand
Studio coworker, Ryan Chen,
just came back
from a 20% project
with NetHope, an organization
that sets up Wi-Fi
at refugee camps in Greece.
This is a camp inside
a departure hall
in Greece for Afghan refugees.
Between interviewing refugees,
he would decompress by drawing.
People started looking
over his shoulder
and asking if he
would draw them.
That's Ryan in the middle.
So he started
sharing his pictures
with the people
around him, people
living in tents who had almost
nothing, but they had rations.
And because it's human
nature to reciprocate,
he was invited for tea.
So Ryan drew even more
pictures, and his host
shared even more of
their stories with him.
And this is Mustafa holding
one of Ryan's drawings.
Ryan graciously allowed me
to share some of his pictures
with you today so that
you can start to get
to know refugees as he did.
And maybe some of you will
want to volunteer with NetHope
and install more routers
in more refugee camps.
I wish I could draw
like Ryan, but I can't.
My passions are
simpler, like corn.
I was raised in a corn-growing
country in Indiana,
and two big upsides of
humid Hoosier summers
were, one, diving into
limestone quarry pools,
and two, corn on the cob.
Turns out quarry jumping is kind
of dangerous and technically
illegal, and tasty corn
is getting harder to find.
In the 1980s, most
farms in my county
were bought out by agribusiness,
and now the corn in my county
is the kind used for cattle feed
and those compostable takeout
boxes.
But when harvest time comes
around, I still crave corn.
So I did my research to
find out where farmers still
grow tasty heirloom corn
like the kind I ate as a kid.
The answer Google gave
me, Oaxaca, Mexico.
OK, Google.
So how do I get to that corn?
Turns out Global Exchange
was organizing a trip
to Oaxaca for Day of the Dead.
I don't go for organized trips.
It's my job to organize
other people's trips.
But Global Exchange
does fantastic research
tracking food
justice initiatives.
The itinerary they
suggested included visits
to a taqueria that exclusively
uses rare varietals of corn.
They have 33 different
corns on that menu.
And this is an image
from Day of the Dead.
This young woman is dressed
in a dress made entirely
of corn husks and corn kernels.
You can see some of
the different colors
of the heirloom corn
that is grown in Oaxaca.
But even more
importantly, the trip
introduced me to Zapotec farmers
who started seed corn banking
to preserve heirloom varietals.
When I got a whiff of that
corn cooking, I thought, yeah.
I get it.
This is food worth
fighting for, and this
is food worth saving
for future generations.
So thank you, Google.
I finally found that
corn I've been craving,
but I also found
my new food heroes.
Now back to you.
Already you have a full
suitcase, solid background
research on sustainable travel,
an itinerary with a rural area
where you're planning
to ask bonus questions,
and a passion you're
ready to pursue
to the ends of the Earth.
But there is one last
thing you can share,
the thing that Google
shares every day.
You know this one.
Information.
This is an Italian muralist.
It says, "Let's all
give each other a hand."
So as part of the application
to join that Global Exchange
trip to Oaxaca,
they asked me what
I was going to do with
the information I gathered
and stories I heard.
Well, here I am,
telling you about it.
So that's one promise
I've kept today.
But there are other ways
to circulate information.
You know the drill.
Write posts, host Wikipedia hack
days to correct misinformation,
and add to our global
knowledge about remote places
that may not have access to
information sharing directly.
Ruben put together this
crowdfunding campaign
for effect.org, and he
whizzed past his goal.
But-- I promised
him I'd say this--
you can still donate and
volunteer with effect.org.
So Ruben, that's another
promise I've kept today.
Or you can do what
Ryan did and volunteer
to install Wi-Fi for
people who really need it.
This boy drew his family a house
with the crayons Ryan brought.
Notice it has a NetHope
Wi-Fi access point.
Join networks with
the people you meet.
Widen the circle to
make room for people
to be heard and get
to know each other.
You'll learn stuff, including
some really random facts
about breathing tubes
and goat cheese,
and you'll make
friends for life.
And one day, after
all this travel,
you may be invited to hang
out with people whose work
you sincerely admire,
people you've been
meaning to thank for a while.
And you won't have to
show up empty handed
or wind up bringing
t-shirts no one wants.
You'll have some information
they might actually
be able to use to help them
make their next trip more
meaningful.
This just happened to me.
Next time, it's your turn.
Well Let's make
this exponential.
One last thing.
I'm headed to Uganda next month
to work on a cervical cancer
awareness campaign.
So if you have family
or friends in Uganda,
I'd like to take
you out for lunch.
And when I offer to deliver
a memento to your friends
and family in Uganda,
you know I mean it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Tying with
the message that you said
and how it relates to the
creation of the books,
you know, the idea to go one--
you know, 10 extra miles down
the road, how do you balance
that with now everybody's
going 10 extra
miles down the road,
and they're all selling
specialty heirloom corn?
And how do you not overwhelm
and keep pushing the frontiers
when you suggest that
people go places?
ALISON BING: Well, the other
part of that going further
is asking more, right?
So you don't just
go for the corn.
You meet the farmers, and
then you ask the farmers,
what else is happening
in the communities?
And suddenly, some of the
slides I didn't put in here,
they say, well, you know,
I like to do woodwork
in my spare time.
Oh, do you now?
And it turns out that the
farmers in this village where I
went for the corn--
let's be honest--
have fantastic-- I
mean, it's a surprise--
it's not sort of UNESCO
claimed or preserved.
It's just a matter
of time, really.
But farmers have been
doing woodworking
in that area for
hundreds of years
now and donating it
to the local church.
So the woodworking
is splendid, right?
So you just keep
asking more people.
And you say, oh.
Well, is anybody else
making interesting food
or doing something interesting
in their spare time?
And they will point you
towards the next village,
and they will point you
towards their cousin
across the valley who makes
this really interesting corn
drink, fermented, that's more
powerful than you expect.
[LAUGH]
That was tasty, but strong.
So yeah.
Just keep continuing.
Use your curiosity to keep
pushing past the limits.
And certainly it doesn't take
a journalistic background
to do that.
It just takes your
sort of natural--
the curiosity that
you apply every day at
work here to your travel.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for presenting.
It's great to hear your
information and how to do it.
ALISON BING: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How do you manage
the language barriers
or differences to really
getting in and understanding
the culture and meeting the
people who may not speak
the languages that you do?
ALISON BING: Yeah.
So it is helpful to do some
language learning before you
go if you can,
especially if you know
you're going to be
going to remote areas.
But there's nothing
preventing anyone
from hiring a local
translator or guide.
I mean, there are
fixers who are used
to this kind of thing
who you can hire
as an independent traveler.
I just lucked out that
when I was referred
to a series of
translators, somebody
said, well, this guy is
really more of a geologist.
And I said, aha.
Because I knew the area
that we were going to
is known for having
prehistoric fossil sites,
and I knew that I
would want to see
what other types
of information I
could get out of him
as a local expert.
So it's trying to find--
trying to see if
you can double up.
Can the person who's taking
you someplace also provide you
with some additional
language learning?
Do they have insights
from their own interests
or careers or
background that they can
bring to that story for you?
And also, you know,
again, because you
don't want to rely on
locals to give you all
this information, triangulate.
See if you can make connections
with places that you're going.
So instead of saying, OK.
Take me to wherever's
important, and then somebody
takes you just to the one
famous mosque in town,
and meanwhile, you're passing
right by this phenomenal school
in Demnate where adults are
doing vocational training
and lifelong learning, and
offering tea to passers by,
you know?
So don't leave it entirely
up to your local expert,
but try to make
some local contacts
and find some information
about where you're headed.
Demnate, it also
turns out, in addition
to having this
phenomenal school,
it is renowned for its olive
oil and a particular type
of couscous, which
remains to this day--
like, I dream about
that couscous.
[LAUGH]
So if you do your own kind
of background research,
historical research, you
may come across things
that even locals don't know.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: One last
question then.
So what determines
something that you
choose to put in the
guidebook or to leaving out
of the guidebook?
ALISON BING: Mm-hmm.
Well, we do consider paths also.
We're aware, particularly
in destinations like Morocco
where people can be--
depend on a guidebook
a lot, because it's
a key source of information.
San Francisco, there's a lot of
information available readily
online.
Not so much in the kind of outer
reaches of the Sahara Desert.
But you have to be
mindful as a travel writer
to constantly be
checking and shifting so
that, one, you're not enriching
the one merchant in town who
happens to sell water
who's in the book.
So is somebody else also
selling water, you know?
Probably.
Can you say, oh, along
this particular block,
there are several
people who sell water.
So you want to be mindful of
not having an undue impact
on a remote community.
And again, like, continuing
every time to check.
See what's going on.
See how that money
is being spent.
Is it being-- is the
community seeing the benefit?
Or is it really just
that one water seller?
There's a story in Morocco.
There is an oasis
that gets bypassed
because it's not along--
you know, a side road was
built. A bigger road was built.
And so now this town
that has a big historic
[? agdez ?] has been
completely bypassed.
And I thought, hmm.
I want to find out
what's going on there.
[LAUGH]
And I had done some
research with nonprofits,
and they said, yeah,
there's a community
garden that's opened up there.
I'm not really sure what
they're up to, but you know,
if you like gardens--
and I knew that
English folks who
are a big audience for
Lonely Planet guidebooks
are really passionate
about gardening.
I thought, I'd better
check out the garden.
So I went, and it turns out
that it's a communally organized
garden that was started
by some schoolteachers who
noticed that kids were
falling asleep in class
and were not growing very much.
And they realized that it
connected with malnourishment.
They weren't getting enough
of a range of nutrients
to support them in
their development.
And so the community got
together, and they said, look.
We've got this patch
of land at the center.
We've got one well in town.
Maybe we can agree
to send some of--
irrigate that one
patch that doesn't
belong to any one person, and
all grow vegetables together,
and agree that this is going to
be for the families who need it
most.
And then if there's
leftover, then it
goes to the other families.
And then if there's--
they couldn't actually
imagine a time
when they would be
leftover after that.
So I met with them,
and I said, you know,
can people come and
visit your garden
without disrupting
your gardening?
And they said, sure.
Anytime.
And I was like, OK.
Well, actually,
it's possible you
would get a lot of people
interested in this garden,
so let's set some times, and
let's set a meeting place,
and let's figure out who's
going to be able to let them
in and show them around.
So they thought it was--
clearly, they were like, well,
this is just a garden that
we've started in our village.
I mean like, uh, I can't imagine
tourists really want to see it,
but OK.
And the next time
I came, they said--
first of all, the
garden had grown.
Second of all, the
children had grown
and were paying
attention in class.
They had been able
to diversify what
they were growing from
simple sort of beans and root
vegetables.
They were able to grow tomatoes.
They were selling them
now to other villages,
so they were able to buy
books for the school as well.
So it had this huge
knock-on effect,
and it was all
individual travelers
coming through, saying, hey.
We had provided a
range saying, you know,
if you want to plant
one row of beans,
you could leave a
donation of, like, $5,
and that would do that
for this community.
And people were crazy generous.
And you know, were
like, well, we
want you to be able
to grow as much food
as your community needs.
And so they were
very moved by that.
The next time I came
back, they said, OK.
So this is great.
Our community is doing well.
We're able to help out
neighboring villages
to pilot similar projects.
And they said, but one
thing we never realized,
we never thought of ourselves
as environmental leaders.
And we have had people
come to us, visitors
not just from the UK, but from
Bangladesh, from Latin America,
from all these other
places, saying,
we could do this in the
place that I'm from.
Do you mind if I
borrow this idea?
And very open source,
they're like, yes.
We'll tell you how to do it.
We'll tell you how to scale it.
We now have expertise
to offer, right?
We can help you model this.
So that all happened
just because there was--
you know, I was thinking,
actually, of our users.
I was thinking of British people
being interested in gardens.
And in fact, it had
this tremendous impact.
And that's something
that anybody could do.
It doesn't have to be--
you all have a
phenomenal platform,
and you invent new
platforms all the time.
[LAUGH]
So thinking creatively
about how you can support
an effort that is ongoing.
Like, that's just
what you do at Google.
You think about
users all the time.
So if you think about
your travel the same way,
what can you do?
What small thing can you do?
What platform can you provide?
It's a powerful tool.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much.
ALISON BING: Thanks
so much, Cliff.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
as